[Musique]
ce week-end je le disais se déroule la
cinquième édition du comptoir de Noël au
domaine de Madame Elizabeth à Versailles
alors je vous le demandais au tout début
d'émission qu'est-ce quelles sont les
activités qui étaient prévues au total
il y aura combien de stands environ 90
donc comme je le disais tout à l'heure
on a mis le paquet cette année le
département
tient énormément à ce à cette à ce
moment nous allons créer un véritable
village de Noël dans le domaine de
Madame Elisabeth avec un parcours un
parcours sucré un parcours salé un
parcours de jeux pour enfants des
foutres des animations je pense que ça
va être un vrai un vrai moment convivial
et familial
et vous attendez beaucoup de monde oui
je pense que cette année il va y avoir
du monde parce qu'on monte en gamme dans
cette dans cet événement de marché de
Noël et c'est vrai que le département a
mis a mis les moyens pour pour
rassembler les familles illinoises au
domaine malgré ce contexte d'inflation
oui malgré ce contexte d'inflation mais
bon on peut pas tout mettre sur le dos
de l'inflation et de la crise
on sort d'une crise sanitaire maintenant
on a une crise énergétique de Majora une
crise autre et puis on aura une autre
crise et à chaque fois on aura un
réflexe de de repli qui n'est pas bon
pour un peuple de se replier et je pense
qu'il faut justement au contraire c'est
dans les moments de crise qu'il faut
investir
j'étais mère pendant longtemps de
Bois-d'Arcy
j'ai été maire à une période où il y
avait une crise économique très très
importante et c'est à ce moment-là qu'on
nous avons investi pourquoi je dis ça
parce que il faut aussi donner aux
familles il faut donner aussi aux
yvelinois l'envie de sortir l'EN l'envie
de vivre en famille de rencontrer de
l'envie de partager de donner le goût de
la solidarité de la convivialité et
c'est pas parce qu'il y a une crise
qu'il faut rester touche chez soi sinon
on vit plus quoi c'est un rendez-vous
attendu important des versaillers et des
yvelinois plus en général alors on a
constaté que bien sûr majorité il y
avait des Versailles mais beaucoup
d'Yves Linois aussi qui viennent à ce
marché Noël qui est devenu manoir
rendez-vous incontournable qui monte
chaque année l'année prochaine nous fera
peut-être encore mieux l'année dernière
on a fait un petit peu moins mais c'est
vrai qu'on est en train de monter 90 ans
de c'est beaucoup quand même avec
énormément d'animations énormément de
surprises et puis je pense que les
enfants vont passer un très très bon
moment merci Philippe je vous en prie
merci à vous pour en parler avec nous on
continue sur le thème de Noël puisque la
ferme de Gally de Saint-Cyr l'école a
tronquer ses citrouilles pour ses
illuminations de Noël depuis le 19
novembre et jusqu'au 18 décembre inclut
la ferme ouvre ses portes et au plus
grand pour son événement Noël et
merveille plusieurs ateliers sont
proposés découvrez-les avec Céline
Charles les derniers vestiges
d'Halloween trônent encore et pourtant
c'est une toute autre ambiance qui s'est
installée à la ferme de Gally guirlandes
et lumière le prouve Noël est à
l'approche
[Musique]
comme chaque année la ferme propose tous
les samedis et dimanche après-midi de
nombreux ateliers à l'occasion de son
événement Noël et merveille pour 13,5
euros les enfants peuvent s'initier à la
boulangerie et à la confection de
décoration de Noël tout en côtoyant les
animaux de la ferme c'est une petite
couronne voilà ils ont fait une petite
couronne
raphia où ils ont dû créer composer
voilà donc on nous fournit le matériel
et il compose comme ils veulent un petit
sapin elle a collé elle a mis des
petites guirlandes des plumes et une
rondelle d'orange une atmosphère
féérique voulue par l'équipe et qui fait
le bonheur de toute la famille une
ambiance un peu chaleureuse avec les
deux corps lumineux l'esprit un peu de
Noël on se retrouve on partage un bon
moment et puis les enfants repartent
surtout avec quelque chose à la maison
pour pour montrer aux personnes qui ont
pas pu venir avec eux et puis surtout
pour mettre un peu de déco chez eux je
voulais faire une activité avec mes
enfants
en plus qui
rappelle Noël donc c'était parfait et
puis on est à Paris donc on est aussi
content de sortir un petit peu de voilà
de Paris et de faire petite activité
voilà en plein air faire profiter des
activités à ma petite fille qui a 3 ans
et lui montrer les belles décorations de
Noël ça leur permet de voir de faire
d'autres choses et donner des idées
aussi aux parents de sortir crêpes et
jus de pomme chaud à la cannelle vous
attendent à la ferme de Gally une
activité à retrouver jusqu'au 18
décembre
[Musique]
on poursuit dans l'ambiance de Noël
c'est un des premiers rendez-vous du
département le marché de Noël de
Coignières a encore attiré de nombreux
visiteurs les samedis au 26 et dimanche
27 novembre de multiples animations et
temps forts
avec bien sûr la présence du Père Noël
c'est aussi un reportage de Céline
Charles il était de retour pour un
week-end le marché de Noël de Coignières
a lancé les festivités dans la ville
grand sapin illumination ou encore
artisanat d'hiver était au programme un
cocktail féerique pour ravir les
habitants venus en nombre malgré la
pluie on commence à profiter
tranquillement des préparatifs de Noël à
se mettre un peu dans l'ambiance voilà
c'est un beau marché qui est bien décoré
donc on tous les ans on vient ici et on
en profite avec les petits animaux les
chevaux les humiliation le Père Noël bah
pour les enfants les la mini ferme là
comme ils font et tous les exposants
le Père Noël pour les enfants qui est
très attendu un marché ou chacun a ses
préférences qu'est-ce que tu peux faire
sur le marché de Noël bah je les bonbons
au total 28 particuliers et producteurs
locaux ont répondu présent plusieurs
exposants venaient d'ailleurs de
Coignières c'était une volonté de la
municipalité sur mon stand j'ai tout un
tas de produits de la ruche en fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui avec avec tout ce qu'on
connaît en pénurie de d'énergie et tout
ça c'est important et puis ça permet
aussi de faire vivre les petites les
petites communes d'avoir une activité
locale sur les petites communes il y a
des sapins de Noël fait avec du coton
démaquillant et après dessus je rajoute
des décos j'aime bien l'ambiance de Noël
et puis et puis c'est sympa c'est
familial sans oublier bien sûr le Père
Noël venu tout droit de Laponie je viens
rendre une petite visite à mes futurs
mes futurs petits enfants que je vais
livrer gentiment que je vais pouvoir
récolter un peu des idées pour prévoir
la construction au niveau des lutins
avec une question que se pose tous
même les plus grands donc il y aura
énormément de cadeaux en attendant les
nombreux cadeaux sous le sapin d'autres
rendez-vous festifs sont prévus dans le
département prochaine date le marché de
Noël de la Ferme du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux du vendredi 2
décembre au dimanche 4 décembre
[Musique]
et après Coignières d'autres communes
organisent leur marché de Noël en
décembre des weekends rendez vous au
samedi à La Verrière sur le parvis du
scarabée à Montigny-le-Bretonneux ce
sera trois jours de festivités de
vendredi à dimanche à la Ferme du Manet
et l'encours organise également à son
événement pendant trois jours ce sera du
9 au 11 décembre sur le parvis de
l'Hôtel de Ville un marché de Noël aussi
à Guyancourt mais un marché solidaire
pour la ville jumelée de Comet au Bénin
c'est le 10 entre 10h et 17h gros
programme en perspective pour le
week-end du 9 au 11 décembre puisque
Maurepas et plaisir proposeront
également leur animation à Maurepas est
au gymnase de La malmedone et à plaisir
c'est dans le parc du château la commune
des Clayes-sous-Bois revient avec la
deuxième édition de son marché du 16 au
18 décembre place Charles de Gaulle et
sur le parvis de l'espace Philippe
Noiret enfin attrape le marché de Noël
se tiendra pendant une semaine sur la
place de la Merise à chaque fois entre
14h et 18h30 pour la première fois
d'ailleurs la ville proposera une
patinoire synthétique dans la salle de
la Meuse et Gabriel vous nous avez de
nouveau rejoint en plateau est-ce que
vous avez préparé vos idées de cadeaux
pour Noël alors pour étonné je m'y
prends souvent en dernier moment donc
pour l'instant pas du tout mais que le
premier dessin donc j'ai encore un peu
le temps et vous c'est pareil je fais
partie de ces personnes qui le 24 au
soir cours dans les magasins pour
essayer de trouver les derniers cadeaux
comme beaucoup de boulanger je suis un
petit peu parée peut-être pas le 24 au
soir mais oui je le fais généralement la
dernière semaine avant le 25 en tout cas
bah tous ces marchés de Noël pourront
nous peut-être nous aider à trouver des
cadeaux et on reste dans une ambiance
hivernale partir au sport d'hiver dans
les Yvelines c'est possible c'est ce que
vous propose de le parc alpin à côté
2100 installé dans le premier depuis le
1er novembre sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou il vous
propose de multiples activités ludiques
qui luge ou encore raclette en
téléphérique Céline Charles vous avez
testé plusieurs activités j'ai testé la
patinoire la luge tant bien que mal et
bien sûr le repas bien dans une
télécabines c'est ça je vous propose de
découvrir ces activités ensemble
[Musique]
faire du ski à quelques minutes de Paris
c'est possible sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou je me trouve
actuellement au parc alpin à côté 2100
ce qui raclette ou encore patinoire
venait découvrir avec moi ses nombreux
activités
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement avec Céline
Caillat directrice de la communication
et marketing de ce superbe endroit alpin
du coup village alpin qu'est-ce que
c'est un petit peu ce que vous pouvez me
présenter du coup qu'est-ce qu'on y
trouve la première station d'hiver de
l'Ouest parisien on y trouve trois sites
dans un site on a une piste de luge une
piste de ski avec biathlon une piste de
ski alpin et une grande patinoire de 500
mètres carrés le parc afterwork avec
trois bars et des DJ à partir de 17
heures le soir et la troisième partie
qui est le domaine de la restauration
avec 150 télécabines et plus de 10
téléphériques qui vont de 8 à 16
personnes dont 11 heures le matin à
23h30
on peut venir déjeuner à partir de 11
heures le matin et toute la journée
c'est un service continu en télécabine
et le soir à partir de 19h en télécabine
pour fondue et raclette c'est vraiment
l'ambiance du ski avec les produits
savoyard un grand sourcing savoyard tous
les produits viennent de savoir et c'est
pour tout public et c'est pour tout
public loin des tout-petits c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 5 ans et on
fait un droit d'entrée mais qu'on
appelle le Pass entrée de 10 euros mais
qui a un bon de consommation c'est pas
une vraie entrée c'est vraiment pour
consommer sur place pour avoir droit à
une attraction à des crêpes et chocolat
chaud et du coup pour la patinoire pour
la consommation d'énergie aussi des
télécabines comment vous avez un petit
peu aménagé ça fait 500 mètres carrés
oui de patinoire un travail avec une
très belle société qui s'appelle
cinerglass où la consommation d'énergie
équivaut à trois foyers de 4 personnes
sur un mois et surtout en tel cabine on
a retiré tous les chauffages qui étaient
présents dans les télécabines les 150
télécabines n'ont pas de chauffage c'est
pour ça qu'on demande nos clients de
jouer le jeu de venir en tenue de ski et
puis on fournit les plaids tous les
jours et le vin chaud moi ça m'a donné
envie en tout cas je ne sais pas où mais
moi tu vas les tester cette activité
bonjour est-ce que ce serait possible de
faire du patin s'il vous plaît vos
chaussures c'est parti
[Musique]
après la patinoire un petit passage par
la piste de luge de plus de 4 mètres de
haut et 25 mètres de long
puis je me suis rendue sur la piste de
ski un tapis roulant en revêtement
synthétique qui permet de s'initier ou
de retrouver des sensations
après l'effort le réconfort en
télécabine avec une carte savoyarde
appétissante ce sera fondu à la truffe
pour cette fois-ci
si vous n'avez pas la chance de partir
au sport d'hiver à la montagne pas de
panique vous pouvez venir vous initier
ou pratiquer ici jusqu'au 29 janvier
prochain
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par ATIS barré bonsoir bonsoir si vous
êtes conseiller en municipal à Poissy
délégué à la biodiversité au bien-être
animal dans quelques instants vous allez
nous présenter une chronique sur la
nourriture qu'on peut donner à nos
chiens ou non